Happy New Year America is still a great
country the best in the world but it's
also fragile wealth and power are
concentrated in fewer hands that at any
time in our history and unfortunately
many of the people who wield it are
short-sighted and unwise
some of them actively dislike the
country they lead that doesn't mean
disaster is coming but it could we have
no idea what's gonna happen in 2018 so
it seems like a good moment to review
the things we do know for sure here's a
partial list of them wars almost never
make countries richer or happier reading
the internet all day does not make you
smarter sending more texts and emails
does not make you more productive you
have an absolute right to say what you
think is true other people may not like
your views tough friendship is more
important than politics
so our sports dinner church dogs and
most hobbies attacking people because of
their skin color is wrong this is always
true no matter what the color is the
beginning of wisdom is understanding how
little you can control gender is not a
social construct it is a biological
reality men and women are inherently
different they are not interchangeable
pretending otherwise isn't just absurd
and anti science it's also a surefire
way to make healthy relationships
impossible families fail and a society
collapse animals are closer to humans
than we think and people are closer to
animals no matter how many public safety
agencies government bureaucrats invent
when it comes down to it you're
responsible for yourself and your family
best to know that ahead of time
the only immutable law is the law of
unintended consequences new and improved
electronic devices rarely improve your
life often they enslave you no text
message or social media post is ever
worth interrupting a meal with people
you love the US government has one duty
securing the well-being of American
citizens relatively few people who work
for the government actually believe that
charity begins at home before you send a
check to fight malaria in Congo or
sponsor a Syrian refugee
Minneapolis asked yourself why so many
of our fellow Americans are living on
the street or dying of drug overdoses
and then ask what you can do to help
laws change customs and beliefs change a
lot changes human nature does not change
any food that makes your mouth water
likely bad for you in the end all that
really counts is relationships with
other people no matter how successful
you are if your kids hate you
you have failed history happened whether
you like it or not and finally you want
to make the world better raise decent
children preferably a lot of them